okay hello everyone we are about to
launch into another wolf and language
design review part of our incremental
language development
uh series and we've got several topics
here so let's start off with palindrome
Q How can there be things to talk about
about this
stand for the integer case to work in
any base
what's the five doing is that the number
of leading zeros and things
correct
oh this is integer reverse
um
so the discussion last time was that it
doesn't make a lot of sense to talk
about palindromes sometimes unless you
specify that third argument
but how do we access that do we want to
do that and how do we do that for power
I have to have a base I mean but
palindromes
for a bio sequence
um
boy This is complicated I mean it's just
not that complicated a piece of code to
say you know integer reverse equals
whatever
I kind of feel like this is a this is a
not particularly good idea I think it's
going to get more complicated inside
palindrome queue than it is you know
we're going to end up with some
elaborate design that's going to say if
you're a bacterium that has you know
this kind of sequence with this
complementation thing then do this and
it's just going to be a mess
I say we don't do this
comments from other people about this
yeah I think this is the same conclusion
we arrived at
the previous time we discussed that
because given that it's a function that
works both on integers and strings and
other things it's difficult to design
only for integers
right
but does palindrome palindrome works for
for
decimal
integers is that right
yes
and if I give it in binary it's tough
luck if I want some binary it's tough
luck exactly
you know I mean that's just freaking
life I mean it's just not hard to say
integer reverse equals equals and I
don't remember a single time I've needed
that well actually that's not true I can
remember a few but no
let's not worry about this I mean
you know and the function repository we
can have an integer palindrome queue
perhaps we already have one
that does the totally obvious thing with
industry reverse
right having separate functions would
allow
the possibility of being more specific
all right anything else here
I think we should just close this
all right that works
let's come to Brett's low hanging stuff
Brett one thing the Brett is here right
yes right okay
that's not very low hanging but it's
really important as the stupid Graphics
throw Graphics grid thing yes
have you solved that
do I need to push it further
I see pads on at least part of it
in the most recent version
if that's what we need to solve
so
it really is really bad it should never
have been allowed to happen it's bad
I mean so I mean I think there's two
things going on
okay one is
you know
a few versions ago
like I think around you know V12
it got slower because we're trying to do
better at the layout
and so we're spending time doing actual
measurements of things
and so that's slow down listen look look
look look look this is kind of there's a
bit more urgency here okay this needs to
actually be solved if you need me to go
try and solve it we'll do one of those
meetings
but I don't want to hear that it's you
know some kind of long-term Five-Year
Plan no it's not a long-term Five-Year
Plan
I mean I responded to you know your
email yesterday and
you know for 13-2 we should get some
speed up
um
we need as much as we want but it will
make progress no no we need to have
something where it is not possible for
it to take a minute
to you know to make a bunch of Graphics
into a row
I just cannot work that way it cannot
happen that way so why don't we get one
of these you know bug investigation
meetings scheduled and I'll look at it
right I mean and and so that's the
thing is that if you'll let me talk for
a moment okay go ahead is
yeah so you sent you know one of these
cases where it was like taking a minute
you know for you or something and our
node and I both looked at it and you
know we were getting results in a few
seconds
and so it's one of those things where
how fascinating
well then debug it with Rocha okay
I don't believe in those things
they you know it's like the famous thing
that happened with wolfen Alpha where
people tried to convince me it was my
network for like seven oh stop it stop
it stop it yeah forever
um Brett this this is a speed issue with
with Graphics bro yes regret yeah and
possibly intermittent
yes okay
yeah if you get a chance maybe send it
to me
particularly if you can make it less
intermittent well
right but I mean my point is if it
really is intermittent
this is which is totally weird right we
gotta we gotta track that down
yes
you know and it's
I mean you know there's been a class of
these things over the years where
you know especially with your
long-running sessions that yeah you know
some State builds up and then you know
some aspect of it
usually is what happened it's a
Communications issue I think
front-end math link kernel
where something
that a very low probability event
happens eventually and we've actually
found and fixed some of these okay but
this is this is happening repeatably
okay let's not derail okay okay okay
yeah
okay
first item here do we have Tim here
I don't think we do
um oh it's
um
my God okay an ISO set of icons are
these in unicode
I don't think so
are you sure why do they have Little
Numbers underneath them if they're not
in unicode
um do you think those numbers represent
Unicode points oh wait I saw okay I
couldn't read them at first now I can
read them you're right
it's just formatted exactly like a
Unicode yeah right yeah it is yes
um
my gosh and you have to buy it for 30
Swiss Francs
this is very confusing
um
okay well I I don't think these are
particularly relevant I don't think we
need a rotary compressor
icon
for your front windshield wiper or no
this one here what's that guy
it looks like an owl that's frowning or
something
um are are they are sorry but the a bit
up into the left in that table are those
like the laundry Direction
icons
like these ones no yeah that does look
to me like oh oh no right I mean the
same general shape but yeah not actually
build a like a windshield wiper icon
yeah they do but what is a what is a
scray
foreign
[Laughter]
um all right I don't think this is the
relevant thing however
you know I mean I think you know if
people do have you know
more common things that they do want to
add and you have like things that come
up in user interfaces like hamburger
menus and you know whatever or something
but I think the whole point of Icon data
okay
the idea with icon data
was to have these parametrized icons
right okay yes okay which I think are
pretty interesting I think that icon
data
oh look okay we got several different
things going on here one is
we know there are certain icons that
we're going to put on maps we want to
have in user interfaces
Etc right so I mean let's let's list
some of the places where we know we need
this stuff okay so we need Maps we need
user interfaces we might need
um
uh you know plot markers are slightly
related to this
um
that comes back to the maps you know
sort of I mean yes it does except that
Maps we want something that indicates
you know a um you know a waterfall or
something you know there's probably a
um uh a thing like that now where else
what other kinds of things do we how we
run into here where we need icons we
need them for yes for I mean we also
have here we've got
uh sort of indicators like temperature
gauges
and moon phases and so on right where
are we going to put a designed moon
phase
um okay what are some other domains in
the world where where this kind of thing
comes up
I know we've had a meeting about this
before we should try and find that
material
um
right I mean the other you know place
where this you know potentially comes up
is
you know I mean further down in the low
hanging list there which is you know the
pictograph type stuff yes yes yes that's
right that's right I'm just looking at
icons and I'm seeing Shiba Inu dog icons
okay that's that's kind of you know by
the time we're at that level I don't
know what
um right I mean and the other thing is
that you know icons
nowadays have overlap with Emoji Emoji
and unicode that we you know didn't have
support for previously right right right
right right right versus emoji
slash unicode
right so I mean there are there are
essentially parametrizationless icons
where I don't know why it isn't just
coming from Unicode unless we don't like
the design from Unicode or something
we don't like the font so it's a
question I mean for maps for example is
there a Unicode area
that just is the um the appropriate
thing for that
I don't think so
it's kind of odd isn't it yeah I mean
like you know the fact that like you
know the icon for a tent for you know to
represent a campsite
you know I don't I mean there are things
that probably look kind of like it as
well which raises the question of of
should we be putting this into eye
contact or should it be some kind of
font
where we have you know something like
you know backslash bracket tent icon
Jose other people I assume Jeremy Davis
isn't in this meeting I can't see where
he would be
this is this kind of thing
um I can see if Jeremy can join yeah why
don't you see
in the vector Maps you will use our own
collection of icons that is in the style
so there is a there are little images
that that go into there right are they
accessible from icon data no I don't
think so
and what are they how do if I just want
one if I want to say in text
you know turn right at the at the blip
sign where blob is a tent how would I do
that
I mean so
the 10 I mean the existing icons the
parameter lists ones
live in the icon entity
type
um
which I mean searching those is
so if I say here entity list of icon
okay
so how do I actually get the icons here
uh pick one of those and grab the image
property
oh hey why don't I just map
why don't just say entity value
let's hope this is cached
why is it what I mean is it because
they're big
do you have any idea why this is slow
yeah there's some intelligent sizing
going on there that's why it was doing
it in smaller batches
okay so what are some of these things uh
so the category is roughly you know
skimming through what you had there we
have the yoga poses we have things that
are sort of map related like those
airplanes and you know Airport parking
in the second row there
we have Olympic events well it's that
guy
which one fish
an aquarium
I don't think so
no it wouldn't be pet store
um it could be aquarium actually
okay and what's that connector doing
right and that's one of the other
categories which are you know basically
electrical connector type symbols so USB
and
um do we just want to say um
do density class of icon
okay yeah okay all right
y class list
uh yes yeah
and the the geographic ones are split
into some of some sub-categories
um you know transportation and service
and yeah I mean this wouldn't have been
my
you know if I were like what icons exist
ontologically in the world
it wouldn't necessarily including the
icons list of icons
wouldn't necessarily pick this along
with yoga poses and no
I mean this is a pretty weird list but
it is
um
I mean that's what you just did
basically
oh it's it's the whole thing yeah okay
um
yeah but if you do like dining icons or
then it's a smaller set of things
why would why do we Okay dining icons
exist because why because we put them on
maps or what yes
hey Jeremy we're talking about icons and
icon data okay and this incredibly weird
collection of I mean these are nice
icons they're well they're weird map
icons meant to be seen very small
but they were mostly you know things
like them existed we just redrew them
right we've got a nice consistent set
here
the question is what is our general but
these are not parameterized these are
just pure
you know
it's a thing I can't even imagine what
that one is
um
and
you know if we were to look curation
wise just for you know a list of icons
out there in the world
what
you know I mean I'm just looking
on the web for you know random you know
lists of icons like here's a random list
of icons that is found on the web
I mean
why what are these for I mean what the
heck are these for example what's this
question is what are the use cases for
these icons
because I mean once you just sorry the
ones you just pointed out look like the
new windows 11 tiling yeah like those
are tiling icons for Windows 11 it looks
like oh okay
okay but I mean
icons as we use them
we often Custom Design icons for
you know for user interface but what
what are our uses let's let's list that
you know
our uses okay for icons
labeling Maps
um
indicators engages a little bit for user
interfaces you know
constructing
user interfaces
I don't know to what extent we're using
them for visualization and that's where
pictograms also comes in right
I was going to say in you know
constructing user interfaces you know we
don't have any of
those things you know like easily
accessible from the system
right right
like you don't have the toolbar on right
now but
none of those icons
I think exist anywhere I mean obviously
they exist in the system
uh preferences
no you can't I'm not sure why it isn't
on right now yeah because I switched it
off but but
why surely it should be from the window
menu oh oh oh yes
um toolbar or Sub menu fourth item down
from the top
default
okay
so you're saying those very icons
we don't have them in a font we don't
have them anywhere
I mean there's some resource that is you
know with the magic incantation you
could get yeah yeah but that doesn't
count yeah exactly okay my question is
this
why do we not take our you know tent
icon or something and just make it a
character
particularly in the modern world of
emojis
can anybody answer that I mean
what's that what benefit would it have
if it's technically a character well we
can put it in text then
I mean let's say the aquarium you know
what other properties does it have okay
so the only property it has
is its image and its name
um
but would you ever want to put it in
text
but some of them yes and I mean what I
admit
okay this one not really I can't imagine
it
I mean I could imagine it in some
tabular data I can certainly imagine it
okay the question is what is this thing
okay so let's say that I have a table
okay I I make a table
of now how do I enter the aquarium so I
would say icon of aquarium
no I would say
control equals
aquarium icon does that work
okay
so probably a aquarium of image right
right which is what I'm going to want
all the time I don't really want just
making a list of the aquarium icons is
not very interesting
it's a bit fishy here I mean why did it
why is it that size
but why for example why did it not get
smaller
how did it pick the size is that an
image
yeah that is an image yes okay so if I
say input form of that actually is it an
image no it's a graphic so why did it
that gets
it must have a fixed no it probably did
get probably did got resized but it
didn't have
the thing
you know the fish was fed too much and
expanded to fill its tank so to speak as
in if I just were to take arbitrary
Graphics here they would probably be
this size that's probably the size right
yes that's the yeah and so this thing
got got you know was you know as big as
it could be so to speak
all right so this thing really is a
piece of graphics
so for example that means that I could
in principle well I can't in fact but
but so for example here's here's a thing
that I might want to do I might want to
say take this and let's say I say you
know something like first of the fish
and then I'm going to say something like
graphics
of
light blue
oops which otherwise not clear how I
would do
right
whereas if it was a font character I do
know how to do that with style
right
and I mean in in maps and things and
different styles of maps don't we need
to recolor the icons
and we do
how do we do it
um list like geolist plot
um you know with icons
will
set the base style I think
for the white is the base Style
oh okay so it's done through base style
I mean it will be much better if we
could just say you know style of
this thing I mean which if it was a
character we could do I'm not
necessarily saying it's right for it to
be a character because the disadvantage
of it being a character is then the
sizing I mean right now you know I can
make you know I can resize the fish like
that which I clearly couldn't do if it
was a character
mm-hmm
and I mean for an emoji we don't have
named can you get to Emoji from names
not through like long name characters
generally
why
I mean it would should wouldn't it be
how do I get to an emoji by the way our
special characters palette does not have
emoji on it which is a shame
and it probably should have right now
that we can do them
well generally it only he has games yeah
with long names
and you know we should consider
generalizing this
I mean I understand that we we I mean
because we built this what 20 years ago
or something now more than that
I mean it's been updated it's it's not
like I mean the downside with that is
that
the set of emoji or Unicode characters
that is available on your system it
depends on your OS version and not on
your right so basically you're saying
use your OS mechanism for entering these
things
John Mack is like you know control
command space right or if you have a
very recent Mac right you just hit the
FN key and it brings up an emoji chooser
I tried that it didn't work
okay
all right so this is
and if you scroll down like it'll bring
the top right if I if I use this
alligator will it now remember crocodile
whatever will it now will it now show me
that crocodile is that crocodile now a
favorite of mine
oh yes it is and you see there's a
search field at the top there
I see
okay all right so then okay but now I'm
having a hard time distinguishing so if
I say Here style the crocodile
um
colors will have no effect on that no I
understand that but I mean if we style
the crocodile at a hundred okay then
it's a that's a nice Vector crocodile
um
and and you're saying that if I color
the crocodile it'll just ignore the
colors
yep
right do I have any way to color the
crocodile I mean I suppose I'd have to
take this
rasterize the crocodile
and then I could say Blend or something
right I mean you could trade I mean I
don't know that it would have any effect
on the mod on the crocodile right but
you could try adding the skin tone
modifiers to see if if
oh no
the
it's not like elephants they don't tell
me it goes from African to Indian
elephant if you add a modifier
um the
um okay as long as I can tell apart in
African or european swallow
right
the okay but in any case
um
so what's the point here so we've got
several mechanisms we've got the Emoji
mechanism we've got the icon data
Graphics mechanism
and is there any other mechanism what
about the plot markers what are they
are markers icons are they an icon data
they are not
um so the sequence used by list plot or
whatever
um when you say plot markers goes to
automatic
is just a list you know it's an internal
list that it goes through it's not
exposed that's bad anyway that should be
an icon data at the very least
um
so now if I say plot markers are
automatic here
oh boy
well hard to tell what's going on isn't
it
um
if I do this is that going to
well it's arguably worse because yeah
okay we're noticing in terms of
in terms of consistency is these plot
markers better be in
um you know should be an icon data
I would assume I mean the point is okay
so let's understand how we anchor these
things so the point is that icon data
primarily
is a name-based story everything has a
name you know
it's got uh you know
big toe pose or whatever it is it's a
name thing
whereas these plot markers might not
have a name I mean it might be a put up
job to give them a name just like it
often is in unicode
you know left Circle you know descending
whatever it is right
um
but okay so of any uh these iconistic
things I could almost say iconic things
the you know they have an appearance
they have a name look actually let's
list off what they actually have
you know in a more General okay
properties
okay
they have a name
they have a graphics appearance
they potentially have a font appearance
and they also might have an image
appearance
so to speak
like for example for Flags you know
flags are a good example because Flags
exist in
you know for us if we say
um
let's say I don't know what has a fancy
flag
um Monaco flag I'm going to guess that
has a coat of arms or something
okay so what we have here that one oh
blast well give me give me one that's
more interesting something with a what
has a coat of arms or something like
that on it
doesn't try like Salvador as a steel oh
yeah as Mexico is good
okay that was quite slow okay but that
is a vector
eagle
whereas we can also say
Mexico
flag image
does that and it's the same one
that's bad
that's bad that should that's an
linguistic that should surely work
um
okay so then we've got flag image
okay and that will be a much lower res
eagle
there we go and meanwhile we've also got
how the heck do I get this how do I get
the Mexican
Emoji Mexican flag emoji I guess I do
this and I search for Mexico
and I pick the flag there along with the
burrito or whatever that is wait a
minute why did that beep why did that
beep at me
I I don't know if you try
um you can try to follow if if you have
wires activated you can try the Emoji
palette uh wires function okay
it's not working
it's not working
out of curiosity what happens if you try
and type that into another window and
then copy it into the notebook
you mean just some other random
application yeah I just want to see if
it's a problem with the Emoji if it's
just a problem with that input mechanism
yeah I understand well let's try and put
it in a web browser
input regards probably a silly place to
put it let's put it into
uh gosh what application so how I try
putting into mail
um
see what happens if I try that okay so
I've got this command shift whatever
press the Mexican flag
well one Mexican flag appeared in email
okay let's go can you paste it yeah yep
hmm
okay well we've got a Bugatti here
okay so the issue there is command can
you know control let's just see what
happens if I try and put if I do this
and I put the the cat icon in there
oh that's really weird
the Mexican flat right the Mexican flag
is two code is two characters I wonder
if that's somehow related
assuming there really is a problem with
Mexican flag well I think there is
really a problem if I tried again
let's just try I can try let's try my
favorite Ram here
you know the ram has no problem
Mexican flag works fine for me uh
pasting into it just beeps let's see
what happens I mean if your insertion
point is after the Ram oh okay let's try
that I'm wondering if there's you know
some issues without having anything
selected so there's also a bug okay
let's try this
foreign
that just didn't work at all that I did
command what the heck I put a Mexican
flag in there and it evaluated the ram
there's a bug here and it might be
because it's a double code point or
something
or your machines haunted
possibly that
um
okay so my point here is the Mexican
flag comes in three variants
right it's a graphic it's an image and
it's a font it's an emoji font character
now I would claim that that same thing
in a sense what we're dealing with here
is
ah how to think about this
you know what we've got is named
iconography
typically or possibly iconography pick
from a palette
um
how should we think about this but it
feels like it you know what we really
need is that the icon entity could have
image it could have Graphics it could
have you know character all three
attributes all three properties rather
am I missing something here
I'm gonna cut it potentially up to that
I mean some of them might be missing or
something if sure yeah if there's no
Emoji if you know if it's uh if it's a
um uh an ant teacher there might not be
an emoji for an anteater
right
because we might not have an icon for an
anteater either
but I mean essentially what we're
talking about here is these like these
these icon things are drawn
you know there's a fairly clear
distinction between an image of an
anteater and an anteater icon
do we do we think that's true
so by image of an anti-durge you mean
like a photo of an anteater yeah I mean
I mean what I get if I say you know
image of an anteater
right
there it is
um what the heck is that wait a minute
that's the leg oh that's the leg of the
art teacher sorry I thought it was
another I thought it was like a panda
that the anteater was friends with or
something
um never mind okay I mean it does look
like that but you know it's probably you
know never mind let's assume it's the
leg of the art teacher but but you know
we can clearly imagine an anteater icon
you know which is very different from
the anteater photograph
you have an icon you could even imagine
putting it on the uh The Entity you know
blob that's a good point a little funky
that's a good point I mean we when we
have icons for things now it's
interesting okay so let's take a corner
case of iconography okay
we've got
for example the symbol for the planet
Mars
okay which is not
I mean that's sort of an icon for Mars
and I mean if we go to Unicode and we
look up icons in unicode
does it have a whole section that um
uh
I'm sure that that symbol is in Unicode
oh yeah I know it certainly is which is
where we're getting it from
um
how can this be
I'm so confused here I'm just looking at
some random site with a with a um
I mean because of course Unicode now now
that there's there's Emoji it's no
longer a standardized
or something I mean because different
people
so I mean this is just a bunch of random
stuff here
see I mean one of the things as a
practical matter when we make icons yeah
okay chess pieces do we have icons
yes I have for a long time
I mean characters or chess pieces for a
long time so if I say bishop or
something you have to say like black
oh so we do I didn't know that okay
um
because then there's the White Version
as well yeah I understand that but so
that's another great example of a
character that is an icon
right whereas we don't have this
as a piece of graphics
we could but the only way you get that
we actually uh well in 13 too
why because of the chess tools thing
that's being worked on
oh
okay are there any graphics versions
they they've gotten some graphical
versions because they
went right when you overlay them on an
actual chessboard you need something
with oh that's a good point that's a
good point that's a good point you're
saying right so that's a great reason to
have
uh okay so then you know if you want to
put them if you want to place these
things
well if you have an inset okay if you
want to place these things in graphics
you need at least an image version if
not a graphics version
right
I mean text version will work no but it
won't resize properly
depends on what your intention is it
would in an inset wouldn't it no I don't
it won't resize by default okay it won't
because you'd have to give it a restart
you'd have to restyle it I mean if I say
if I do this if I say you know Graphics
of rat table of inset of the chess piece
how do word clouds work then it doesn't
seem right those are they a text
uh it's text with the font size set to
scaled I believe
which I think you can do within set too
so what would I do I would say
um
right here
I just say random real 10-2 or something
here
and then um
okay so generically there there are my
whatever those things were
um
Queens I think yeah okay all right so
now if I say in here Style
of this thing and then what do I say
font size
what do I say here the font size goes to
scout of 0.05
when you put it in a s never mind
okay
but now but now try rescaling that
graphic
yeah that will work
if I rescale this graphic those guys
will all stand in absolute size yep
but if this thing was I mean isn't there
a thing that takes this and makes glyphs
out of it what was that is that a WR
thing that makes Cliff out of a font
character
um
we do have a way to do that right
because we can turn this we don't have a
way to do that and I don't remember what
it is right now
actually that there's a thing that's
called um
image Graphics right
but it isn't image this isn't image
Graphics that we want this is
um and if I take that and I give it I
think I'd have to rasterize that
okay
there was a way to do it with uh export
to PDF and re-importation
this is image mesh but this isn't yeah
right there was a crazy way with the PDF
import I think there's yeah there's an
image measure kind of image binary eyes
not yeah there's there's a way to do it
this way too
if you just want the text as a mesh
there's a thing with boundary
discretized graphics
oh that's too weird anyway but look look
basically the point here is
we've got these different modalities
forgetting what is essentially an icon
graphic
and
what do we think that the right way to
do this is is the right thing to have a
you know a standardized bin that we
throw all these things into where we
have you know an icon for Mexican flag
an icon for anteater if we ever Drew one
that basically every time we draw an
icon including all the ones that we draw
for our internal purposes
that we give it a name and throw it in
the icon
entity store
with properties that are these different
things
would that be a sensible way to do it
and then
you know then we can palletize so to
speak
a different meaning of palletize
um the uh
uh
you know
um these things so that you can pick
them like this
does that make sense to people I mean in
that way what we would do is we would
take you know all these different
sources of icons which means the plot
markers the internal interface icons Etc
and
uh
you know and centralize them all inside
icon entity store the icon entity store
is that sensible now what that doesn't
get for us is the parametrized icons
things like those wind maps and so on
right I think those you know have to
live in icon data
well no doubt but I mean we have to
think about those more carefully but
you know is there an obvious distinction
between I think there is a pretty
obvious distinction between the
parameterized and the non-parametrized
ones pretty obvious at least
and now the question is should we be
able to access let's say we have a named
thing in icon data in in the icon entity
store
should we also make that be a thing
which is a character that you can access
with backslash bracket
or is that crazy probably that's crazy
that's crazy because then we have to
have a Unicode code point for it
right it has to live in the private
space
potentially and
it just gets messy all right so comments
from people from Jose for example in
terms of of okay so I mean right now we
have icon we have an icon entity store
but right now it only contains the
vector graphics
right not even if there was
a unicode
character it is not in there
does that make sense so we that's a
piece of curation to match those up
Jose does that make sense to you
um yes yes
um so for us there are two main ways we
would use icons one is in geomarker in
general the second argument of Geo
marker so we can place anything we want
anywhere
that's very useful through icon data the
other ones are the icons used in the
vector Maps those are very specific and
those are
determined by the style so every time
that the style of the vector label map
is downloaded which we do once per week
um it comes with its own icons and it
will use only those icons
okay so wait a minute
yes a different issue you're describing
the the the thing you're describing the
issue of maybe we want the equivalent of
different fonts
for different stylings of a single icon
see what I'm saying because in other
words
right I mean you're saying if I look at
our icons down wherever it is like the
fish icon here there could be multiple
just like you know there are multiple
ways to render the character G or
something there could be multiple
different ways to render the fish in
different essentially icon font families
well I mean if we add your marker we can
use whatever icon we want and your
Market doesn't have the the capability
of restyling for example if that's black
your marker cannot change it to red
it will go as it is but no
what's that
geomarker I mean geomark if you set
geomarker within geo-list plot it will
get styled
if you put something in the second
argument
maybe it defaults your marker gets
styled but I'm referring to no style
wait a second okay Steven to G on this
part of random geoposition comma of 10
geomarker goes to the goldfish
okay jealous plot
oh oh sorry never mind Jose I was
getting Geo marker and plot markers
mixed up
plot marker is the option geomarker is
the thingy it does yeah
so I'm referring to you Marco yeah yeah
yeah
so if I say plot markers and then the
fish
is it going to
what's that what's the pink what's the
pink
multi-transform getting screwed up
well I mean I think it might be because
the fish is is cut off by
oh this is not good
well it did restyle the fish
restart the fish but it also re
rearranged the world as well
I know I know I know
so okay so those are the random
positions now why is the fish not not
it's very fishy what's going on
yeah
that I'll look at
that yeah I mean I'm not totally
surprised because
that fish is a it's a complete piece of
Graphics which is well and good but now
I'm curious if I were to put a um
uh wherever I had it
uh if I were to put a ram in there
as a character
it's probably gonna run into the same
issue
let's go yeah it's just a smaller pink
box another small Ram in the top left
corner
oh I see okay so this needs to be fixed
what does work yeah can you try putting
it in a list I'm wondering if it's
I mean I wouldn't expect you know given
how it's behaving I don't think that
will make a difference but
just
um okay
so okay let's come back to what
all right so there's the question of
different renderings of these things so
we've got let's say we've got an icon as
the anchor name
and then we've got sorry go ahead yeah I
mean I don't know precisely how
Geographics works right but in a lot of
these things
right the the icon isn't actually there
right we essentially have a pointer to
Icon which is you know a front-end
resource and so then when we want to
update our Styles we just update the
front-end resource and all the objects
get the new version of the icon
so you know there's another question of
you know
would this thing return the pointer to
Icon and yeah because that's a separate
issue that's another kind of thing which
is a a indirect front-end resource you
know asset resource
that's another type of thing I mean that
that's that's an orthogonal issue that
is it could be an image that is a
front-end asset or it could be a graphic
that's front-end asset or it could be an
image that isn't a front-end asset and
it's just inlined
right is it a point or is it in line
right that's what you're asking
Okay so
okay look what I think
is that we should review all these
sources and we should plan to basically
put everything into the icon entity
store
that's what I think
and try to get these different you know
gradually build up these different
things there now
you know and we should get some kind of
palletization of the icon
you know it's a different okay this is
reminiscent of the color Repository
okay question except Messier perhaps
well okay larger perhaps could this be a
repository
is that a better solution
where one can in principle just deploy
new things
and and name them in some way
in other words could it be the case that
icon data actually this is an
interesting idea that icon data becomes
like net model
something that has a repository as its
backing
because otherwise one of the issues is
going to be how do we document icon data
right it's got you know it's got random
things like dining places and so on
whatever it's going to be a very weird
piece of documentation
so I mean you know right now we're
planning a color palette repository
which hopefully is in Fairly Advanced
stages of development
I think we also think that we want to
have a plot themes repository and we're
going to have a style sheet repository I
think we also want to plot teams
Repository
and maybe we just want an icon
Repository
comments Jeremy anybody else here
I so it makes sense from a documentation
exposure point of view but worries me
that it implies some
giant effort to fill it out whatever
that means oh no no I don't think so I
think we just put whatever we put in it
yeah and that's the advantage of a
repository
I mean I'm just concerned that that well
you know I think my concern with the
repository is that
you know there's I mean like when you
were doing your searches earlier you
know everybody's created you know their
sets of icons for things and
there's gonna be whose sets of icons for
what you mean on the searches on the web
or search results yes like you know the
websites that you you were where you
were searching for icons
and you had you know you know the dog
you know themed ones or whatever
right yes so
you know sort of
for a given name there's 20 people's
interpretations of what that looks like
I just put in a link that's a good kind
of representation of the coverage
so like 5 million I think they have an
API yeah they have an API they do so
technically these are
but Creative Commons with attribution
and I think you get to pay to get Beyond
attribution
there might be some partnership here but
this is great coverage I mean you type
in something you'll expect to find it
whereas our repo
I don't think you should expect to find
anything yes right on the other hand
yeah I mean this is the other problem
that we you know we have gone and you
know had people actually draw icons
that are are consistently slow like that
guy wouldn't be consistent with our
style
right
and I mean in practice Jeremy when we
need icons
how much of the time I mean we end up
redrawing them don't we essentially all
the time we can never reuse an icon
yeah we always redraw them why because
of the styling issue
yeah typically yeah and we just don't
borrow from other people either you know
yeah yeah right I understand but I mean
even if it was a free icon
you know it would not work in our style
probably not yeah I mean so across the
domain yeah everything's consistent
like the yoga or is self-consistent I
don't know if it's consistent with
everything else we do
it looked fairly consistent yeah
um
all right so this is icons here
but it's a you know it's a great site
it's useful and the main thing is you
type something you're gonna find it
and that's how it's useful whereas I
worry about a repo that sparse wow not
sure what the expectation is going to be
well I think that the point is that it's
going to be look it's like neural the
neural net Repository
you use it because there's a workflow
that uses it so to speak that is
the thing with the neural net repository
is is the value that adds the fact that
if you get your neural network from
somewhere else it's you know it's not in
a consistent format or anything but here
it's just you know I'm sure that these
Services can provide these icons in a
format that everyone can use
okay so let's take that let's take this
wolf here
I see so you've got some
customize this icon I don't know who
uses that that's not something a serious
designer would need that's more consumer
the colorization and stuff
yeah I mean
go ahead yeah go ahead I was gonna ask
if they're always vectors
the sources Vector I think you can get
that bitmap in other formats but yeah
it's SVG for all this stuff
so why did that you should press to get
this icon button yeah then you get a
paywall right so it's like they don't
want you to just take everything
right I think technically it's free
but again it's there's a licensing issue
with with all the free stuff
right
so I mean if I say
um let's try something more bizarre
let's try tungsten
oops yeah okay
I mean it's not clear these are useful
but let's try something like um
well I don't know whether this is maybe
liberally
another verse icon is that a yoga pose
in the beginning of the second row I
like the Doctor Strange Love Rocket well
but the next one over yeah that's nice
ugh
um
one of the things that we try here we
could try let's try anteater
I bet they'll have something for that
yeah but I mean okay these are amusing
but as you say we've never used these
well what would you use I mean I don't
know some of those like the ones on the
second row like the well I think we'd
redraw it because we'd have to we have
to make the anti to fit in with our
you know I mean this doesn't fit with a
crocodile Emoji it doesn't fit with our
but if it's just consumer somebody who
uses our product that wants an icon then
this is all perfectly acceptable they'll
have some sense of what they want and
there's different styles yeah that's
right that's true
and
okay so you're never gonna have an
anteater icon
yet you know have somebody draw you know
all the animals for us
I can't imagine it it I mean it just
seems you know I mean you're gonna be
drawing C elegans or something right but
the question is
okay why do people use icons the answer
is they use them when there are lots of
something and they want to put they have
a big table they have a big
uh you know they have something where
they are trying to pack
they're trying to pack them okay a
couple of uses
okay uses of icons
is
seems to me there's you know uh uh
placing something
with information EG on a map
EG mapper plot
another thing is uh you know indicating
the meaning of a word indicating or
highlighting a word and indicating
meaning or highlighting a word
that's like our case where
um you know that's what we do often in
user interfaces
if that makes sense right well we where
we show an icon along with a word
um another case would be in a tabular
and tabular data
uh you know economizing on space and
tabular data
what other uses
I mean road signs you know but that's
not our use case
you know this is the way to the ant
teacher enclosure
what are the uses
okay give me some use cases like for the
anteater icons where would people use
the anti-toe icon
I love the way we have such a talented
group and such silence
if we were having a company picnic and
we had little Zoo displays it would be
an icon on a map to show where that
particular animal was located yes
right so so for the zoo designers this
is a useful thing to have I was gonna
say so if we give each department I was
thinking and mascot
I was just thinking the department
members Maybe
the front end Den
Mark right Colonel stand does it get its
own special icon damn straight
um okay but any case seriously what okay
so I wonder whether this thing has most
popular icons I wonder whether they have
any kind of information about that
um
if if we um
I mean I wonder what happens if I type
in nematode
it's so sad if it was Will from alpha it
would ask did you mean a toad
no no no no this is this is getting rid
of nematodes I assume
it's not they just they get such a bad
rap the
um uh the people who like them call them
skelegans
right
that's pretty lame okay so I mean but I
don't know what we would use that for I
I mean what are some things that we've
had to draw icons for it's I did what
are some things we've had to draw icons
for in in summary blobs
um I mean if I say Spa Sarai
I mean we don't we don't draw icons I
mean no I mean I mean
okay fine verification test has a check
mark for example right yeah okay we have
an icon for Astro position which I don't
like very much which is a telescope
right but the one the ones I create well
I guess there are a couple of exceptions
like link object which have icons but I
mean they're typically very specialized
um
right but like sparse array right I mean
that's an actual visualization of the
data yes right which is useful okay
unless it's really big in which case or
too high dimensional in which case it
shows kind of an icony thing well it's
the visualization uh right but that the
way that icon anything was created was
by doing the exact same thing to you
know a particular data set and removing
the color yeah yeah
um
I'm not even gonna try typing it really
hard here I mean we have other like
schematics like you know region member
region nearest nearest I guess these all
have schematics but they're not icons
you've refined here
yeah I think I mean I think
verification that's the only one that I
think people you know anybody who's not
a welcome language programmer would
recognize as an icon right I mean the
other place that icons get used heavily
is in things like system modeler
that's a good point yes
hold on hold on hold on so that's the
use of Icon so that's that's a um uh uh
what is that that's like circuit
diagrams Etc exactly
circuit diagrams flow charts
um basically
you know this is
what is the general name for this other
than visual programming I mean what is
the general name for
uh
yeah I mean if we say actually an
interesting one what is the icon for a
photon
that's pretty bad you see the fact is
that they're
for the physicists in this you know
that's a that with that weird Arrow
there is a Feynman diagram but the
photon part of it is just the squiggly
part
you know what I'm saying and yet they
don't have an icon here and that's
something that okay that is a good
example and I can't what's the first
icon in that list
that's not useful I mean a photon is a
single squiggly line okay okay but but
just just I mean just to be clear
another Point here is uh you know we've
got parametrized icons
okay and one class of those is eg wiggly
line photons
because that's a that's a type of thing
we don't have like like in the in the
case of Icon data right we've got
um
let me use this technology here no no
that does the wrong thing that's this is
the one
um
in the case I think that's actually a z
particle not a photon but
what
I'm just being contrary
I mean how can you feel that's a photon
and not as and not a z yeah okay okay
fine it's a gage boson of some kind the
um okay but in any case
in icon data so this is the thing we
don't have right now draw a wiggly line
do we have any way to do that do you
have any way to specify that I I'm
drawing a line it's like an arrow
right how would I draw a wiggly line
Brett
not sure I mean you'd probably like you
know construct something with parametric
plot or at least no I understand that's
what I would do yeah I understand how
we'd actually do it in there yeah but
what I'm what I'm saying is something
like a wiggly line from here to there
seems to me like a parametrized icon
in much the same way that this is a
parameterized icon which happens to be I
mean that happens to be a vector
parameterized icon which is defined by a
vector
as opposed to a parameters icon defined
by a scalar here
and and what you would give it like the
coordinates yeah just like you do an
arrow okay I mean arrow is an overlay to
line
I mean you might give a line I suppose I
don't know not sure I mean it um
right arrogance around things that are
not just line or am I confused no you
know you're right either like an arrow
um
or uh a style specification for a
um for eg a an edge and a graph
because that's another case you might
want it you might download a wiggly line
in a graph as you would for finding
diagrams for example
all right listen I I think that the my
conclusion from this is that we should
expect to expand the icon entity store
we should Spruce it up a bit with these
other properties
and we should expect to turn it into a
repository
and we should put into it you know
whenever we create this you know we
create musical instrument icons for some
random reason we put them in there we
create icons for uh I don't know you
know we need icons for uh um filer of
animals or something
um you know we we put those in there
Etc
and you know we just make it a
centralized repository for all icons
that we need
and maybe we have user contributed icons
although then we're going to end up with
icons not in our style but just
maintaining icons that we ourselves use
seems useful because if somebody wants
one of those icons for something they
know it's going to be consistent Etc and
it seems like a useful place for us to
put things because we keep on needing
icons for all kinds of random purposes
and I don't even know what happens when
we want to recycle an icon that we used
in a menu and we want to recycle it in
an ITI blob so to speak
how does that even work does just
somebody from design just say here's
here's the you know here are the assets
for this icon or what
Jeremy well so a lot of these anti-blobs
or visualizations
create Vector art that gets passed and
you know so a lot of stuff will come
through us but a lot of it's like
representative visualizations
fair enough like you know a better
example Germany would be like you know
I'm making something and I want the same
icons that are used in
you know like you know in the tongue you
know I want the well I mean I guess
those are characters technically but
um also we do have a lot of icons and
resource not resource objects but
basically in the front end exactly yeah
you know
a lot actually so so most so the icons
used in Wayne Right the little
there's a lot of icons in the the Wayne
UI and I think that's all baked into
some resource right I mean we've also
got icons like we have somebody drawing
constellations right now we've got all
kinds of random icon art
and I think what we're suggesting here
is to just you know centralize the icon
art
which seems sensible to me
uh
technically so would some of this get
cached into the product absolutely it
would get cash lots of stuff will get
cached but there would be a repository
from which you could get additional
assets I mean you know probably you know
maybe we could use for the kernel at
least we could use the same caching
mechanism that we do for every other you
know Repository
thing and we could pre-cache a bunch of
stuff but that's you know the really
common stuff
um
I think I have to go but but this this
was a useful conversation I think the
the so that's you know why don't we
think about that possibility should
icons only be vector
or no I think I think what we should do
is for every icon we should try to
provide a font version if there is one
if it maps to Something in Unicode an
image which we can programmatically
generate from the vector if we have a
vector and in some cases sorry there
isn't a vector though there isn't a
vector version yeah and you know you
specify that icon that icon name as a
plot marker it will just use the bitmap
okay I have a whole collection that we
did for Alpha right these sketch icons
right and they could they could go in
there they're nice but they're very
different than a typical icon
right but I mean you know I think even
for our own management purposes having a
single icon repository would be useful
yeah um and uh
and then again as I said we need a
mechanism for turning families of icons
into pallets which should be rather
straightforward I mean it's a piece of
code basically just says take this and
this and this and put you know put put
it in a palette
um
and you know I think that's that's the
story for the for the what can we say
the noun without adjective or something
the UN uh the UN unvarianted
uh icons
then there's the problem of parametrized
icons
which
I think icon data is the only only I
mean it could be done in a repository as
well
I mean then it's like a mini function
repository right a parameterized icon is
a function basically that takes in a
parameter or some family parameters and
returns a graphic
so it's like a very Junior version of
plotting
Brett does that make sense to you I
think so I mean and I think you know to
some extent
you know as you say those could you know
you know like what's an icon data right
now you know conceivably you know in a
different world could have been
individual functions in the function
repository yeah well they could or it
could be an air temperature plot
except we don't want that we want
something which is a a
I mean really what this is
I mean perhaps it's just another
repository I mean we have a repository
of icons that are static icons and we
have a repository of Icon functions or
something
that is icons that take arguments
which should not be merged with the
other icons because they have a lot of
different attributes
I think that's the least crazy thing
because otherwise what's going to happen
here is we're going to put random stuff
into icon data it's going to become
undocumentable
Etc whereas if it's a repository it's
okay that it's got you know 50 random
things that were developed at different
times for different purposes and so long
as it has a consistent look I think
everybody is happy
I need to go to something different in
fact another live stream here
um
uh great okay
um
well we got through one thing I think
this was a useful conversation
uh and to be continued another time
okay so okay see you guys soon bye for
now